ok so I call it booze chests I got the
con yeah Kroy al-azhar King Queensland
vodka obviously that's the queen old
steed whiskey that's the horse centaur
guy
chest mate let's just drink
whoa check out this guy didn't do it you
don't arrest me help you all suffer it's
my costume for the pole dancing class
I'm taking up at the Rec Center let's
good way to meet babes right it's a good
way to keep the body in shape and yes I
have met some friends who are ladies
Sheryl penny Lori we're all gonna make
homemade pizzas later it's good
so wait everyone wears a cop outfit or
what oh no no this is just something
fresh I'm bringing to the table
I think I might change the game though
after I see this little routine check it
out freeze I'm gonna need you to spread
on my I like it so far
oh my oh there it is
eyes down here fellas eyes down here
seriously dude you got a pretty good
oh yeah I don't know my teacher says if
you don't sweat in your crack you're not
doing it right